assim eu sou sincero eu acredito que
assim como foi comigo é maioria das
pessoas que escolhem jornalismo
profissão acaba escolhendo isso por um
desejo de interferir no mundo de fazer
um mundo melhor e quando eu entrei na
faculdade onde se entra na faculdade não
das primeiras coisas ensina é que o dos
pilares do jornalismo são a verdade o
compromisso com a verdade e com o
interesse público
eu entrei no jornal assim como formei eu
entrei num dos três grandes jornais de
belo horizonte trabalha como repórter
fotográfico e foi uma experiência
incrível que eu pude ver várias
situações as situações mais diversas
possíveis
depois disso junto com outros três
amigos a gente monta uma empresa começou
a atender outras áreas no mercado mas
continuando sé continua até hoje
atendendo principalmente para a folha de
são paulo
é ele o trabalho desses fundos
reconhecimento que ele teve foi foram
muito fortes que foi foram selecionadas
pra últimas cinco edições do livro chama
o melhor do fotojornalismo brasileiro
onde pra mim foi muito satisfatório
porque eu pude itália ao lado de vários
fatores foram referência para mim
só que nesse tempo trabalhando o mercado
entende que a lógica do jornalismo do
mercado jornalismo a vida real é bem
diferente aqui que eles ensinam pra
gente que os pilares deles são um lucro
ea manutenção de poder veículo de
comunicação a eles acabam sendo usados
como ferramentas é o primeiro que são
empresas a empresa precisa ter lucro e
no caso dos veículos de comunicação a
principal receita desses veículos é
vende anunciantes e decisão disse antes
dois que a gente vai chamar atenção mas
são os governos e as grandes empresas
então como o dinheiro vem dessa galera
aí eles em nenhum momento eles podem
interferir não não vamos dizer assim
nessas empresas ou no governo por
exemplo é um dos papéis que eu vejo
jornalismo é fiscalizar e eu não imagino
eu não tenho certeza que nenhum jornal
vai fiscalizar os seus principais
anunciantes dele é e aí com isso acaba
acontecendo também a disputa por
audiência na disputa por público e no
caso do jornal impresso aqui de belo
horizonte o público dos três grandes
jornais aqui é considerado classe a
então ele acaba defendendo os interesses
também dessa classe um exemplo
compartilhar no meu caso da fotografia é
sempre que a gente fazer uma pauta que
tinha que voltar com um personagem que
não era um personagem definido
a gente tinha que evitar negro evitar
pessoa feia evitar a pessoa obesa e
pessoa pobre qualquer pauta a gente
fosse fazer tinha que tentar achar o
penélope cruz usou a voltar para o
jornal e se fosse pra cá então isso não
sair mesmo existia esse tipo de filtro
na hora de se fazer uma foto e outra
coisa é a concorrência é o famoso furo
jornalístico
o que a gente entende o senso comum é
que o furo jornalístico é o que
determina o jornalista é bom mas na
verdade isso é uma decorrência da
concorrência alguém tem uma informação
que os outros não têm
se realmente uma das bases jornalismo
interesse público
o certo seria um conteúdo colaborativo
né
uma maneira de todo mundo colaborar um
com o outro com as informações que têm
de fazer uma coisa mais completa e mais
informativa só que o mercado não dá
espaço para isso acontecer é e os
profissionais acabam sofrendo com isso
porque muitas vezes profissionais assim
como eu entro no mercado com essa
intenção e no caso do jornalismo
impresso por exemplo é comum isso estou
falando é comum um editor altera
completamente o texto desse repórter
mudando às vezes enfoque mudando às
vezes até velocidade
as informações ali quando isso acontece
o repórter ele tem o direito de escolher
se ele quer ou não sancionar a matéria
e quando ele escolhe não assinar vem
escrito da redação
então vocês pensaram em um jornal que
tem muito da redação inscrito já sabe
por que que é isso acaba interferindo
mais ainda nos profissionais porque é
ele com isso o relato de uma amiga minha
ela falou recentemente comigo ela falou
que está começando a ficar com medo de
sugerir pautas o veículo é o trabalho
porque ela já está com isso a entender
que as pautas que interessam ela nunca
são tratados da maneira como ela
gostaria que fosse
e por que isso é ruim porque o
jornalista ou repórter de rua que vai lá
que bota a cara conversa com as pessoas
entende que está acontecendo e por mais
que lá na frente ela decida não assinar
aquelas pessoas conversaram olhar no
olho dela
as pessoas sabem que foi ela que foi lá
então isso acaba comprometendo um
trabalho dos profissionais também é em
outra coisa que acontece no brasil e são
dados de 2009 do projeto que chama os
donos da mídia
ele constatou que 271 políticos
brasileiros são donos ou diretores de
324 veículos ou seja como que esses
veículos vão fiscalizar o próprio chefe
no próprio dono então já é uma coisa que
tem que questionar o pior disso é que
existe na constituição federal artigo 54
que proíbe que políticos sejam donos ou
diretores de veículos
então é uma coisa muito e se questionar
e que pouco se questiona
vou dar alguns exemplos aqui de como
isso é grave
a tv mirante é a retransmissora da globo
no maranhão
dos quatro só esses dois são políticos
um deles é roseane sarney atual
governadora do estado no seu segundo
mandato
e o outro josé sarney filho que é
deputado no seu sétimo mandato
consecutivo
essa é a segunda na tv gazeta
lá no na lagoa na lagoa e transmissora
da globo em alagoas e que um dos sócios
quando collor de mello não precisa nem
falar mais nada dele né que atualmente é
senador e que minas tem em casa o que é
curioso isso aqui é declaração de bens
do aécio neves para o tse em 2010 e pode
mudar
ele declara nove centavos de ações nos
diários associados
imagina se a gente perguntar para ele
falar é esse valor tão baixo das ações é
tão pouco e da constituição proíbe isso
pode pegar mal não sei que pra mim é
porque isso acho que ele poderia assim
não são pelos nove centavos é e aí eu eu
acho que eu entendo hoje que a
compreensão do que é jornalismo
de uma maneira geral está muito
equivocada e pode mudar é porque as
pessoas se o público em geral eles dão
muita credibilidade para os veículos de
comunicação
sai na tv é porque é verdade ler um
jornal é porque é verdade
pouco se questiona isso e eu acho que tá
na hora de mudar isso e se apresentando
um cenário onde se pode começar a
acontecer
primeiro pela internet porque foi um
ambiente onde novos veículos poderão
surgir várias independentes via mídia
ativismo mídia livre esta ou seja um
ambiente onde pode surgir um monte de
coisa
em paralelo alternativa à mídia
tradicional
outra coisa é o que a gente chama de
jornalismo cidadão que existe graças a
esses novos aparelhos que permitem
fotografar filmar e compartilhar ea
outra coisa é são as redes sociais que
graças a elas é fica fácil você tem
acesso a esse conteúdo está sendo
produzido compartilhado então no nos
protestos de de julho do ano passado
acho que foi um momento na história
brasileira onde mais se consumiu o
conteúdo independente
isso realmente fez a diferença foi a
primeira vez que eu vim assim pais
amigos meus
o show na globo foi a porto vivo aqui na
globo e vi esse vídeo e internet é
diferente a versão que a globo foi a
primeira vez que eu vi realmente alguém
que você é esse contraponto à mídia
tradicional tendo realmente voz às
pessoas realmente conseguindo ver isso
aí eu vou dar alguns exemplos agora o
primeiro que eu queria dar uma olhada
antes
é esse o perfil das pessoas está mudando
muito também tem uma pesquisa que foi
encomendada pela secretaria de
comunicação da presidência desse ano que
constatou que 47% da população
brasileira já se essa informação pela
internet a tv continua sendo o principal
meio de atingir as pessoas 97%
mas a tv está perdendo espaço entre os
jovens justamente onde a internet ganhou
espaço então realmente isso é um cenário
que está muito no começo é que a
tendência é esse mudar muito rápido em
breve é o primeiro exemplo eu queria dar
um exemplo foi uma referência para mim
foi em londres 2009 teve encontro do g20
e tiveram protestos lá e aí um homem
dono de uma banca de jornal
voltando pra casa passando pelos papéis
ele morreu
a versão oficial da polícia foi que ele
morreu de causas naturais e que os
oficiais foram impossibilitados de
atendê-lo porque os manifestantes
estavam é tacanho garrafas neles tudo
mais só que aí começou a surgir na rede
social gente falando por mim para eu vi
um policial batendo nele ouvindo aqui
não sei que o jornal um álbum jornalismo
de gard então jornal britânico começar a
pesquisar em um deles o ponto iter
fazendo um chamado assim por quem tiver
alguma imagem uma coisa aqui sobre isso
até semana pra gente e aí chegou à
seguinte imagem pra ele era um
investidor de nova york e em londres
tirou o celular dele começou a filmar
sem buscar nada aparentemente sim muito
natural esse é o tchan
de costas o policial é atacado que
aconteceu é quando o delegado fez ele
soltou a imagem na internet e aí o que o
tempo depois das flores oficiais lá
pedindo para tirar do ar ainda tentava
esconder a história mas que foi
jornalista cidadão ele desmentiu uma
versão oficial da polícia metropolitana
de londres
os outros dois exemplos que eu vou dar
aconteceu comigo no passado
é durante os protestos de julho aqui ou
no primeiro dia que ainda ninguém
esperava realmente tem que acontecer é o
que me chama muita atenção foi a
violência da polícia polícia tava a
página estava respondendo àqueles
protestos com uma violência desmedida
assim no primeiro protesto teve uma hora
que eles avançaram se ela tirou a bola
debaixo do chão correndo e houve aquela
primeira queda dos adultos nunca caiu de
cima do viaduto e aí o filme isso aqui
logo depois a gente com gentileza 1 caiu
na 18ª e se alguém caiu na estrada santa
rosa não na unidade na confusão para
falar da seriedade dessa queda nos
outros dois protesto que aconteceu
depois de se mas cinco pessoas caíram e
10/5 duas faleceram
então esse vídeo ele a qual acabou sendo
quase 400 mil visualizações que já foi
pra mim uma surpresa e o pessoal da
globo - me procurou e vai incluir isso
no jornal mtv não entende realmente a
possibilidade que eu estava tendo lide
eu dizendo se incluir todas as pessoas
independente estamos registrando de
realmente interferir na mídia de pautar
a mídia
nesse caso é outro exemplo
a gente foi para brasília que durante
para a gente cria um grupo de ativismo
ea gente foi para brasília e levá o
modelo vigente é feito para o sete de
setembro
aí aconteceu isso aí
a definir
já falei pra você sorrir a favor do
casal gay
o último momento você definir um
objetivo de repente pode estabelecer
metas pra você
o nosso objetivo é chegar no congresso
com a nossa bandeira
então bruno é a gente não ultrapassa o
limite do senhor impulso e mesmo assim o
senhor agrediu a gente com gaza
sim porque o capitão bruno
ele admite uma arbitrariedade ea nora de
agredir a gente e esse vídeo me
surpreendeu mais ainda porque foi de 7
de setembro de noite a gente soltou o
vídeo no dia 8 esse vídeo alcançou quase
um milhão de visualizações e de noite
ele começou a faltar a mídia de novo
pode mudar seu próximo e ele entrou para
a capa da maioria dos portais folha onde
próximo ea rua
g1 e aí pra nossa surpresa no dia
seguinte a gente acordou eo jornal de
brasília é como se fosse um super
notícia pegou frente e colocou na capa
e aí dentro do carro a gente ligou o
rádio escuta a seguinte entrevista
mas ela é uma imagem silenciosa na
imagem editado pela sua presença aquilo
ea pessoa quer mostrar o capitão nesse
caso especificamente a imagem toda a
mostra que o capitão foi diversas vezes
é tentado por aquela pessoa que estava
fazendo isso e é importante que se diga
que não era um jornalista
eles têm um filho capitão respondeu
tecnicamente o mais de cinco vezes pra
ele o que porque ele tinha lançado o gás
lacrimogêneo naquele espaço
e aí uma das vezes que o capitão não
tinha respondido por diversas vezes
tecnicamente o capitão vai falar e vive
já que você não tá
o que o capitão que conseguiu já que
você não sabe o que estou dizendo
então eu fiz o que eu queria era o
comandante da tropa e no vídeo mostra
que o capitão estava cumprindo ordens
léo que chegou lá e falar olha não é
tratado aqui tem passado aqui é pra
lançar caixa
então talvez mas ninguém gosta no banco
mas esse é um ponto que eu ninguém
passou e se estabeleceu no início
ninguém passou ali e ainda sem agredir
as pessoas
eu não tô vendo se o comandante da
polícia militar já está desculpando uma
arbitrariedade covarde de um comandado
eu fico imaginando colega soft dessa
apuração que a apuração teremos de
execução teremos só por o a polícia
militar armada
o dinheiro do contribuinte fardada com o
dinheiro do contribuinte já agrediu o
contribuinte de forma e ainda tenho o
comandante o seu o seu tempo ao tema da
responsabilidade que que é no que é
imensa quando o comandante vem a público
já para desculpar uma coisa que é tão
gravemente tão claramente é abusiva como
como como mostra esse vídeo fica
imaginando que isenção terá a comissão
que eventualmente esteja seja feita o
trabalho de investigação da corregedoria
que vinha sendo feito é se ela está
contaminada com algo com a avaliação do
comandante que houve fraude que houve
abuso o abuso foi da vítima
quem mandou botar a cara limpa tomar
porrada é desse jeito com a comandante
só ficar finalizando o seu subordinado
que vão apurar esse caso ia que vão
apurar com o que maneira de vender fazer
deve concluir suas investigações ou não
bom
conseguimos fazer um comandante da pm de
brasília tomou um puxão de orelha ao
vivo na rádio
é bom isso aqui são exemplos que eu
ainda acho que são muito pequenos ainda
do que que ainda pode ser feito não
queria dizer que a chamar atenção para
todo mundo quer fazer jornalismo seja
jornalista ou não que a rede proporciona
para a gente fazer um jornalismo de
verdade num jornal de mercado
o jornalista a gente aprende na
faculdade obrigado